I'd like to welcome our special guests
for named Murphy principal analyst for
security and risk at Forrester and Ben
McCormick vice president of operations
that Evernote Rene can you tell us a
little bit about your work at Forrester
on security in the enterprise and how
cloud figures into that yeah so I work
at Forrester as a principal analyst in
governance risk and compliance so I work
with chief information security officers
on the risk question about the cloud and
from a security perspective I'll say
that that's usually the very first
question they have how secure is the
cloud are they gonna be responsible for
you know my problems the first thing you
try to do is tell them you know listen
you know take any cloud best practice go
into your own data center and see if
you'll pass that and they'll come back
and tell me there's no way we can do
this I'm like right well then not much
left to talk about me is like someone
else can do a better so I think that's
how they they first come to the question
like what am I really giving up and I
say you're not giving up anything except
you know the spinning disk in your space
that's all you're giving up you're
actually enhancing your security you're
enhancing your availability
what makes cloud more effective is you
have the you can hire people I can't
hire you can have you know huge data
centers maybe being all of googles oh
okay
um you can do that right you can do it
in a way I can't and listen the more of
us that go to the cloud the better
you're gonna get at it and the better
you get at it the better I'm gonna be at
it and I think at the end of the day you
know if you're in the business of doing
anything other than managing data
centers then why are you managing the
data center then let me bring you in
last year you did migrate your data
centers over to Google cloud tell us a
little bit about that experience does
the security side of that mirror what
renee is talking about or did you have
other interests and concerns I'd say
broadly yes for us it was about allowing
our teams to focus on what was important
to our end customers we've got hundreds
of millions of users who we are helping
collect information and retrieve
information and help them be more
efficient being an expert in running a
physical data center doesn't directly
report that so for us it was about
allowing our technical teams and you're
right you you move to cloud you do not
get rid of your technical team yeah or
if you do you're gonna realize it's a
mistake really quickly
there are there are things you're doing
the physical data center that will be
replaced in the cloud you need to become
an expert at the clouds the cloud
providers control plane etc etc but for
us it was about focusing our company and
our staff on things that were important
to our users and also allowing our
development teams and software engineers
to move a lot faster so for us the rate
of change in the rate of innovation in
the cloud space is way fast and we can
ever achieve that's the proposition in
cloud that it automates a lot of the
rough work you don't pull cable anymore
you don't destroy hard drive anymore you
know you you outsource all that to
another provider in a large centralized
area and developers can move faster they
have better tools they can scale
ultimately security questions are about
having your business relationships
threatened and you must have had
security questions going in what were
they like and how were they best
addressed so for us to I think it was
twofold we initially started with our
standard security questionnaires and we
went through those and then what our
security team actually did was paused a
couple of months in and actually started
risk modeling or threat modeling what
were the risks that were we looking at
in cloud the risk model is not is the
cloud provider provider going to lose a
hard drive the risk model is what
happens if you lose your effectively
your root password in the cloud account
in your cloud account so we we went
through our standard process first we
learnt from that in the first cycle and
then we updated our threat modeling and
then we ask the questions to Google and
reengaged and I think the other thing we
just went through a period of learning
that you have to to go to cloud means
you've got to trust somebody is there
some kind of corollary where security is
concerned are the security teams working
in different ways on more valuable stuff
it's broadly exactly the same so the
security team and that the legal teams
have still got to verify all of the
certifications with the provider you've
got to go through this security
certifications the questionnaire
none of that changes but what the
security team is not having to do is
audit and we use this example physical
hard drive destruction they're not
having to audit physical hard drive
destruction logs every quarter and for
us the question becomes if they're not
doing that what can they be spending
their time on they can spend more time
on securing the application more time
helping our developers write more secure
code and more time chasing people that
are trying to hack our application not
trying to hack our physical data centers
so for us it I think in the security
side as well it allows them to move up
the stack and focus on things that are
more important to our customers and also
mean that that's what it's about it's
about your customers it's not about the
running physical data centers in your
office or it you're offering your team
more interesting and challenging work it
is a new landscape what do you wish
you'd known beforehand about security
specifically for us that there hasn't
really been there's no beans there's
been no big surprises on the security
side we we did all of our due diligence
up front our security team and our legal
team spent a lot of time with the Google
teams understanding the nuances of cloud
what did it provide what didn't it
provide the big surprise for us has been
how quickly our software engineers
embrace the cloud and in some ways we're
having to play catch-up it's interesting
you say this because you're telling me
that you know the IT teams stay in place
security stays in place they're involved
in different work so there's some change
management involved and you see a
competitive differentiator for the
enterprise and going to cloud what was
that about I think you would look at the
macro picture
we're losing the battle breaches are
getting larger and larger threat actors
are getting more and more sophisticated
and as an industry I'm not sure we're
actually winning that battle but if you
can focus less on some of the security
layers and allow your cloud provider who
has scale who can apply automation who
can apply we hope in the future machine
learning to some of those things it
frees up security professionals to focus
on our applications security and I think
it's one of the ways that we may start
stemming the tide of losing the battle
again talks and ranae you speak to many
businesses how does security figure in
for most of them as becoming some sort
of competitive differentiator what we're
trying to manage businesses when they
talk to me they're trying to manage
reputational risk right and so what do
you end up with after a breach you have
damaged reputation right and so
everybody's trying to control that and
actually it's how they get funding these
days we don't talk about threatened
vulnerabilities anymore we talk about
the impact of the to the business its
reputation like what are we gonna be
labeled you know another company who
can't seem to keep their data together
right will there be a massive fine well
and will there be a massive fine yeah
that's not even funny anymore so you
know we can't ignore it so I think from
a differentiated perspective that if you
are spending your time like Ben said
working on other things securing your
application you know making better code
having security deployed somewhere else
so that they can be meaningful I think
that's all part of being you know a
differentiator a competitive
differentiator and of course you know
the customers are also thinking how's
this going to change my life and so for
a security engineer
when you talk about cloud security and
you know how pervasive or full-stack or
you know depth of hardware software
security integration whatever what are
they thinking about what they're gonna
do next if that part of their job goes
away yeah see that's it we spend a lot
of time telling them we need to figure
out a way to get you out of the
day-to-day stuff of security looking at
patching you know looking at incidences
I'm trying to figure out if the threat
and vulnerability management system is
giving us false positives so for me it's
all about managing that third party
having a partnership understanding who's
responsible for what negotiating that
ahead of time right in a breach who
notifies who of what in a security
incident how is how are we going to
communicate that because you may be
communicating to me but I need to
communicate to an entire organization so
we need to be in sync with that we need
to negotiate change management we need
to negotiate incident management if I'm
in a heavily regulated industry and
you're making infrastructure changes I
have to know so transparency is
available exploit it use it as much
lutely do it and if you're in a heavily
regulated industry have one conversation
with the regulators before you go
down this road to understand their
expectations and if you have internal
audit have them involved the landscape
has changed and I think the next
generation of IT professionals security
professionals need to be cloud ready
they need to be less thinking about how
do I secure a Rooter am more thinking
about how do I secure my cloud account
how do I secure my keys and continue on
that journey so I think it's a journey
up the stack for all of us and when I
started in the industry we used to argue
about what physical network card to put
in a server yeah we did it was an
argument it took you a month of time to
discuss what version of card you would
put in and we're constantly moving up
the stack and it's it's only gonna
continue and it's gonna move faster and
faster and then what do you see your
eyes security teams working on a year or
two from now so what we're trying to
assess is how far can we go down the
route of service architectures not
worrying about infrastructure continuing
to abstract further and further away
from the underlying infrastructure we're
not sure it's quite there yet but we
know it's coming very very quickly we
want to be ready to embrace more
integrated and automated stack basically
basically yeah I'm bracing things like
cloud functions and embracing those
higher value services like Renee said it
like while worried about securing the
container worried about securing the
code worry about writing secure code so
for us it's it's a continual abstraction
it's never gonna stop and it's only
gonna get faster what is the future hold
for security what do you see happening
next when you think businesses should be
thinking about well I think businesses
should be thinking about getting
comfortable with the idea that you don't
need to manage this yourself I think we
should see this as fully outsourced from
a security perspective between the
managed security service providers or
cloud providers I think we should we as
organizations should get out of that
business we shouldn't be in the business
of securing data we should have
companies that are very good at securing
data we should share that risk with them
right we should do that because you
hired all the best people that I can't
afford right you hired all the best
people that I got a point board so I may
as well have you manage that for me
listen if I'm in the business of doing
research should I be in the business of
you know
data center again no no I shouldn't be
right other people are better at it
talk to the provider get a roadmap for
what's gonna get automated next and
think about the value-added security
layer you might put on top of that it's
great advice